when you sell Stay Ready a while back I
rolled up to a gas station in a superar
and started pumping gas and a kid comes
up to me and he's like hey do you want a
free sample of perfume I was like yeah
sure he squirts my wrist he asked me if
I want to buy the bottle I said no but
you know what I'll give you 20 bucks
just for trying to encourage
entrepreneurship and he says cool do you
have 20 bucks in cash and I said no I
have a card though and he was like okay
let me go get the card processor so I'm
standing there my gas is pumping and I
see him just stand there as another guy
is pitching some group doesn't say
anything for minutes my thing clicks and
I was like all right take it put it back
step in the car he sees me and is like
whoa whoa whoa bro bro bro I started
driving away he's like hey man I'm about
to get the thing and so I said listen
man I'm driving this car because I sold
the way you're selling I get it so let
me give you a couple piece of advice if
you want to take them one as soon as the
customer says they'll give you money
shut up the second thing as soon as
someone offers you money always have a
way to process the money third if you
have a closed deal and someone else
walks in you tell the person who's about
to walk in to wait you have the deal on
the table you made all three mistakes
this will teach you far more than my 20
bucks would I've ever given you